irritable bowel syndrome or IBS is a
chronic condition affecting your large
intestine your large intestine also
known as your colon includes the
seeum ascending
colon transverse
colon descending
colon sigmoid
colon
rectum and anal canal
the muscular wall of your colon
contracts in a rhythmic fashion called
peristalsis to move the intestinal
contents toward your
rectum as it contracts your colon
absorbs water and nutrients from
partially digested food moving through
it waste material called stool is stored
in the rectum until it is expelled
through the anus as a bowel
movement
with IBS the muscular contractions of
your colon are
abnormal in some cases the contractions
may cause food to move too quickly
through your
colon as a result your colon does not
have enough time to absorb most of the
water from your
food this condition leads to a watery
stool and
diarrhea in other cases the contractions
May cause food to move too
slowly as a result your colon absorbs
too much water from your
food this condition leads to a hardened
stool and
constipation it is unclear why your
colon contracts
abnormally however if you have IBS your
colon may be more sensitive to certain
factors such as stress that seem not to
affect most
people other symptoms of IBS incl
include abdominal pain and
discomfort
bloating
gas and
cramping you can manage your IBS
symptoms through a combination of
dietary habit changes Stress Management
and
medications eating food high in fiber
creates softer bulkier stools which may
prevent [__] colon
contractions fiber also helps relieve
constipation Stress Management therapies
such as hypnotherapy and yoga may help
relieve your
symptoms your doctor May prescribe
medications to help manage your symptoms
such as anti-constipation drugs to help
regulate your bowel movements
anti-spasmodic drugs to minimize muscle
spasms and reduce pain or sedatives and
anti-depressants to relieve anxiety
and elevate your
mood